du continent ont la toucherait presque
elle se tient là à bout de bras pourtant
lille 2 kg akissi oignies semble si
lointaine elle nous invite à un voyage
dans le temps pour y aller il faut
attendre que le vent se lève c'est
boutre sont le seul moyen pour
l'atteindre
c'est la même histoire depuis des
siècles
non
vous
on
[Musique]
c'est moi le capitaine de se battre j'ai
commencé ce métier il ya six ans matin
mon travail c'est de transporter les
passagers en moyenne 50 personnes
montent sur mon bateau chaque jour à
peine une demi-heure plus tard et bien
youssouf le capitaine abaisse la voile
pour débarquer les passagers sur cette
île oubliée
il n'y a qu'un seul village et pour
cette bourgade de 800 âmes un simple
port suffit ici on débarque les pieds
dans l'eau les buttes ramaré attendent
leurs prochains clients entre ces
bateaux et qu'il voit c'est une histoire
d'amour qui vibre depuis bien des
générations
[Musique]
la vie commence sur le rivage hakim
c'est depuis toujours comment prendre
soin de son bateau c'est sa seule
richesse son unique moyen de subsistance
nos ancêtres sont nés puis sont venus
d'arabie
ils ont pris la mer sur ces buttes pour
venir faire du commerce ici en afrique
afrique et comme ils sont arrivés avec
ses bateaux et bien on s'est mis aussi à
les utiliser tout notre mode de vie
dépend de ces boutre mais sur l'île tout
le monde gagne sa vie grâce à cet
héritage nous allons pêcher en mer moi
je récolte du sel et c'est notre moyen
de déplacement courante est cambrésis
mais si tout le monde sur l'île vit de
l'océan
certains habitants n'ont pas le pied
marin sur une plage dissimulé de kilwa
c'est un genre de pêche bien particulier
qu'on se prépare
[Musique]
c'est à marée basse que tout recommence
à chaque fois il faut marcher sur des
kilomètres s'approcher au plus près de
la barrière de corail pour trouver le
bon filon
sur l'île monde sourit et le virtuose de
la pêche aux cailloux ils les ramasse
avec une main de maître
je ramasse ses pierres puis je le mets
dans des sags rehana pas toutes celles
que vous voyez ici peuvent être utilisés
mais moi je choisis à chaque fois les
plus beaux morceaux sapata mentaux ainsi
je prends les pierres les plus blanche
ce sont celles qui donnent le meilleur
résultat et casey travaille très dur je
n'ai pas vraiment choisi laquelle elmer
bon en fait tu n'y a quasi je n'ai pas
trouvé mieux mais bon comme je fais ça
depuis des années
j'ai de l'expérience pendant une bonne
réputation
ces cailloux bis corning ce sont des
petites pierres de corey moore monde
sourit et ses collègues en ramasse ainsi
plusieurs tonnes chaque année pour
obtenir de la chaux ils les entasse
avant d'allumer un foyer en respectant
des règles ancestrales le métier je l'
ai appris grâce aux anciens mon enfance
je les ai observés puis imiter c'est sur
le tas que je m'en suis sorti petit à
petit ça entraîne au bout de quelques
années on arrive à un bon niveau
ce brasier on verra des signaux de fumée
pendant trois jours et trois nuits
indiquant tout villageois que leur
déconstruction a sonné c'est le moment
pour monde sourit de s'éclipser
son travail n'est pas fini mais personne
ne doit découvrir où il part
[Musique]
au village on attend impatiemment le
retour des pêcheurs de pierre attinois
ces petits cailloux rythme la vie de
l'île
ghani ce puis bien sûr il a été fait
avec des pierres de corail et de la chan
comme vous pouvez le voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans cette île pauvre et isolée les
villageois ne peuvent compter que sur
eux mêmes
c'est l'océan qui leur donne un abri des
puits aux maisons tout village né du
corail les petites pierres brutes forme
les briques la poudre de corail sert de
chaux et certains un peu plus riches en
tire même de la peinture maîtriser
toutes les facettes du corail est
devenue la passion de bidet sa maison il
a construit de ses propres mains
regardez ma maison j'ai pu la construire
à l'aide de pierre de corail médias
chrono et de shows de corey j'ai pris
cette terre et la chaux j'ai mis de
l'eau puis j'ai mélangé le tout après
j'ai pris des pierres je les ai placé
comme ceci et puis j'ai utilisé le
mélange pour faire tenir le tout
mais ou bidet n'a jamais appris à pêcher
des cailloux lui ne sait qu attraper des
poissons et comme il est l'aîné il doit
subvenir aux besoins de sa famille alors
plusieurs fois par semaine il abandonne
les siens dès la tombée de la nuit
[Musique]
allez tirer tirer ça vient venez par ici
les vernets wazi tirez tirez vous du
mois et j'ai 15 ans vont viser vous
savez ce métier de pêcheur au fond nous
l'avons hérité de nos anciens lille
étant entouré par la mer dès la
naissance
nous nous retrouvons au milieu de l'eau
ça ne peut pas nous laisser indifférents
dès qu'on est enfant on tisse des liens
avec l'océan et on se met à la baisse
naturellement je sais le faire depuis
toujours comme hobby des et ses
collègues lance le filet 5 à 6 fois par
nuit ils entourent les poissons et les
crustacés puis les et frais pour qu'ils
se jettent dans l'émail
parfois ils font assez de prises pour
vendre leur pêche aux marchés mais la
plupart du temps ces poissons leur
permettent tout juste d'améliorer leur
quotidien
aujourd'hui on n'a pas fait une très
bonne pêche
mais on désespère pas qu'on va continuer
il est 3 heures du matin la marée
devient trop haute pour poursuivre c'est
l'heure de rentrer
[Musique]
de la petite pêche pour manger des
pierres de corail pour construire des
maisons
si la mère permetta ou guidé sa famille
de vivre le quotidien n'est pas facile
sa vieille maman on voulait presque à
cet océan de ne pas être assez généreux
avec ses enfants
jusqu'à ce jour ce jour ou au bide et
est revenu avec une nouvelle incroyable
oui moi je sais que j'ai de la chance
mon fils apprend un nouveau métier il a
un vrai travail à présent il peut nous
aider comme ça et je n'ai qu'un seul
désir qu'ils apprennent encore plus haut
qu'il devienne encore plus qualifiés
c'est aussi dans mon intérêt s'il gagne
mieux sa vie est bien moins le nouveau
travail dominé lui a changé la vie
il lui permet d'assouvir sa passion pour
les pierres de corail d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui il compte sur une livraison
importante c'est monde sourit le roi des
pêcheurs de cailloux à kilwa qui va lui
fournir la marchandise désiré monde
sourit là c'est donc prendre que des
petits cailloux a décidé de partir à la
pêche au gros
encore plus loin au large là bas il sait
qu'il peut trouver des pierres de corail
bien plus importante et plus rentables
je travaille toujours sonne comme ça je
suis tranquille et je me concentre sur
ce que je dois faire c'est pierre
demande une attention particulière il
faut y aller avec discipline et méthodes
pour bien les choisir
à qui doit on les appelle aussi les
pierres sales et seulement deux souris
c'est à quel endroit il faut les
chercher
il passe des heures à sonder l'océan
pour trouver des coraux aux dimensions
parfaites
ça ne marche pas cette pierre est trop
petit
par contre regarder celle ci les plus
grosses plus de putts à lyon vous pouvez
en faire ce que vous voulez comment
c'était oui elle est vraiment bien celle
là elle n'a pas de défauts il n'y a pas
de cross n'est pas poreuse parmi tous
les coraux fossilisés éparpillés sur les
plages de kilwa monde sourit en extrait
les plus beaux spécimens
il faut faire vite avant que la marée ne
monte et les recouvre à nouveau
sur le chantier au bizet prend livraison
de sa pierre son travail peut commencer
au bide et on a bien conscience
il ne sera jamais pêcheurs de petits ou
de gros caillou mais aujourd'hui lui et
pierre de corail
il sait les tailles et comme personne si
je taille les pierres de corail
c'est pour apprendre à bien faire de la
restauration quand vous mettez à la
reconstruction
vous tombez toujours sur de vieilles
pierres abîmées qu'il faut remplacer
donc si je maîtrise la technique je
n'aurai pas de problème pour les tailles
et c'est là où il faut
à kilwa les habitants comme aux bides et
ça peut encore construire leur maison
avec du petit corail mais ils ont oublié
à quoi servent ces gros caillou c'est
pierre imposante ce sont celles
qu'utilisent et leurs ancêtres pour
ériger des monuments
aujourd'hui les villageois ont une vaste
ambition faire renaître leur passé
[Musique]
car sur cette île se dressent des
vestiges parmi les plus anciens
d'afrique de l'est
des oeuvres historiques insoupçonnées
désormais classé au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco
ici c'est la plus grande et la plus
vieille mosquée soit elie du continent
c'est encore sur cette île que l'on
retrouve les restes du palais le plus
original de cette partie du monde
pendant longtemps personne ne s'en est
souvenu 7 au moyen-âge que des
commerçants venus de la péninsule
arabique arrive en vue de la côte
tanzanienne il accoste avec leurs
boutres sur l'île de kilwa qu'ici où
annie ce brassage entre arabes musulmans
africains puis indien donne naissance à
une culture unique la civilisation
swahili encore présente sur toute la
côte tanzanienne aujourd'hui pendant les
siècles qui suivent kilwa devient l'une
des îles les plus attractives de l'océan
indien
son aura religieuse et son rôle
commercial en font un point central des
routes maritimes bien plus important que
zanzibar
pour faire rejaillir son passé enfoui
la tanzanie a demandé l'aide de la
france forte de son expérience en
conservation du patrimoine
un architecte supervise tous les travaux
il porte un nom prédestiné
il s'appelle pierre leslie donc c'était
des commerçants ici il importait de
l'ivoire des peaux de léopards dépôt
lyon des choses comme ça et ce qui a été
le grand grand grand commerce de kilwa
c'était lors ils sont toute la côte sud
donc le trafic d'or était sous le
contrôle de qui doit les apogée de kilwa
qu'on correspondent à des époques où on
a besoin d'ordre par exemple lorsqu'on
se changes la monnaie or en europe
ça correspond à un projet qui doit
lorsqu'il ya la grande peste en europe
qui est la guerre de cent ans
eh ben ça correspond aussi un déclin de
kilwa donc qu'il doit ces nécessités une
ville essentiellement qui vivaient du
commerce
[Musique]
forts de leurs richesses
les sultans et riche d'un palais
somptueux il innove dans leur
construction
ainsi ils bâtissent une piscine
octogonale d'une architecture unique en
afrique à l'époque et avec vue sur
l'océan indien mais très vite kilos à
perdre le monopole du commerce de l'or
lille décline et sombre dans l'oubli
les habitants vol les pierres sales et
pour construire leur maison ils pillent
leur propre histoire
aujourd'hui chaque coup porté sur le
corail est un hommage aux anciens les
habitants de kilwa ne détruisent plus
ils bâtissent c'est ainsi qu'au vide et
recolle pierre par pierre son passé ah
oui j'adore ce travail est bien sûr il
me rapporte de l'argent mais ce n'est
pas tout l'allier il est très important
aussi je regarde cette mosquée par
exemple la resterait est une excellente
chose
je pense qu'il était indispensable de la
réhabiliter ça revient à lui donner une
nouvelle vie avant ces travaux elle
était bringuebalante elle dégringolait
eh bien on s'est mobilisés et on la
répare et bien sûr c'est dans l'intérêt
bien compris de la tanzanie mais aussi
de kilwa qui six mois
[Musique]
pour la restauration entoure la tanzanie
employer une centaine de personnes à
kilwa il était important de former les
habitants de la région à prendre soin
eux-mêmes de leur héritage
[Musique]
mariam au fait partie des tous premiers
ouvriers embauchés
elle travaille ici depuis deux ans pour
elle ce chantier était un moyen
d'acquérir son indépendance
j'aime bien ce que je fais ce travail me
plaît ça motive d'apprendre le métier
d'artisan masson je veux savoir bien le
faire j'en ai besoin
cette restauration a donné un nouveau
visage à kilwa le village a enfin repris
sa place sur la carte de la tanzanie
des jeunes ont pu trouver un emploi
stable sur l'île ainsi à 30 ans passés
mariam on a pu imaginer offrir un avenir
meilleur à ses deux enfants oise
c'est sur ce que je gagne n'est pas à la
hauteur de leurs espérances
mais le peu que j'ai obtenus jusqu'ici
me permet d'envisager un futur plus
intéressant c'est comme ça que j'ai pu
commencer le chantier de la nouvelle
maison
qu'est-ce que je serai contente quand
cette baraque sera terminé avant de
travailler sur le chantier je ne savais
pas faire tout ça par mois j'ai appris à
construire grâce à la restauration des
ruines
maintenant je sais me servir des pierres
de la chaux et de la terre
pour dire vrai ce type de travail ne
doit surtout pas être réservé aux hommes
il nous incombe aussi à nous les femmes
de faire les mêmes activités
on peut tout à fait y arriver je veux
savoir
truire et je me sens même tout à fait
capable de les pêcher rang mais
aujourd'hui ce chantier de conservation
touche à sa fin les monuments sont
sauvés bientôt mariam ou et les autres
villageois devront arrêter leur travail
sur les édifices et les habitants de
kilwa nourrissent d'un nouvel espoir
partout ils font savoir que leur île
abrite des merveilles historiques
désormais ils attendent les visiteurs
[Musique]
saïdi a vite compris la chance qui
s'offrait à lui dans l'espoir de cet
essor touristique
il s'est formé à l'école des guides puis
il a appris l'anglais tout seul pour
être capable d'accompagner les visiteurs
étrangers sur ville
j'ai deux semaines et a sommé les pipots
zago introduce un bon je pense qu'il y a
tellement de gens qui parlent de kilwa
maintenant mais qui ose des gens qui
nous font de la promotion explique ce
qu'il ya sur l'île du coup de plus en
plus de gens vous venir ici et ils vont
adorer les paiements pipeau keim qui loi
et même si les responsables du projet
partait bien on va quand même continuer
à nettoyer le site
même moi je pourrais entretenir les
ruines pour les touristes saïdi est le
premier témoin des changements sur l'île
auparavant seule une poignée de
visiteurs se déplacer chaque année à
kilwa ce sont désormais plusieurs
centaines de touristes par an qui
visitent les ruines
et
pour les swahili de kilwa c'est boutre
représentait la seule trace de leur
passé les marchands arabes s'en était
allé en leur laissant en héritage
[Musique]
grâce à leur travail sur les monuments
les habitants redécouvrent aujourd'hui
leur histoire et s'enrichissent de ces
vestiges
certains espèrent même voir les
traditions orales renaître derrière les
pierres la voix des anciens père ceux
déjà la vieille conteuse du village
murmure à nouveau ces légendes remplie
de rêves et de sultan d'espoir et de
princesses de boutre et d'océans écoutez
écoutez il était une fois un sultan qui
n'avait pas d'enfant il a fait un voeu
si j'ai un enfant je ne braderai pas je
ne ferai pas la bourre